The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today
what we want to do
is use the two papers that
you read as kind of a backdrop
to try to think something
about the regulation of genes
in response to
changing environments.
So there's the
Mitchell paper that
is talking about this idea
of anticipatory regulation,
whereby if the
environmental changes have
some typical pattern, then maybe
the cells can take advantage
of that and start preparing
for environment number two
when the cell sees
environment number one.
But in other cases, it may be
that the environment fluctuates
in ways that are really
fundamentally unpredictable.
In that case, you can't use the
sort of anticipatory regulation
strategy, but instead,
there may be a way
that you can just
stochastically switch
between the different strategies
and implement what's known
as a bet hedging strategy.
And this is modeled
largely on the work
that you just read about in
the Kussell paper, Science
maybe May 2005.
I do want to stress,
however, that if you observe
phenotypic heterogeneity
in a clonal population,
that does not necessarily mean
that the cell or the population
is implementing one of these
bet hedging strategies.
In particular, I would
argue rather strongly
that there are other
possible evolutionary drivers
for such phenotypic
heterogeneity
in the population.
First of all, just
because you see
some phenomena does not mean
it is necessarily selected for.
So it's possible that it's a
side effect of something else.
However, if you're looking
for an evolutionary kind
of explanation for
something like this,
bet hedging is not the only one.
In particular,
we'll talk about two
other possible
explanations, and they both
have to do with kind
of game dynamics
that we might illuminate
or talk about.
But I guess our game
theory talk was--
that was a week and a
half ago, almost two weeks
ago now-- so maybe you've
forgotten all the game
theory that we discussed.
But in particular,
it could be that
the phenotypic heterogeneity
might be the implementation
of a mixed strategy.
Or possibly it could be
an example of some sort
of altruistic self-sacrifice.
And we'll try to explain
the theory behind each
of these three things as well
as possible biological examples
of each of the three.
In this case, we may
think about bet hedging
as maybe an explanation
for antibiotic persistence,
this idea that cells can
switch into these slow-growing
persister states
in which they're
resistant to antibiotics
and other stresses.
Mixed strategies
could be-- well,
we're going to argue
it could be implemented
in the context of mixed
sugar environments.
And altruistic
self-sacrifice may
be the explanation behind
colicin production in bacteria,
so it's a toxin.
So I want to start by
thinking about this thing
about adaptive prediction
of environmental changes
by Mitchell.
I think this is a
very interesting paper
in a number of different ways.
One is, I think that it's
sort of a big idea that
can be explored in these
simple experiments.
I think that it's an
exceptionally clear paper
in some ways, and
that they really say,
oh, we're going to propose
that this strategy should
be characterized by
these three things.
And then they go and they try
to show you the three things.
The figures, I think,
are also very nice,
in the sense that
in many of the cases
you could have shown the data
just in the context of a table,
where you said, oh, for
each of these strains, this
is the up regulation or so.
But if you had done that,
it would've been much,
I think, less compelling,
even though of course it's
the same data.
So I think this is a neat
paper, in my opinion,
both from the standpoint of the
ideas that are being explored,
but also because it
highlights some of the things
that you should be
thinking about when
you're writing your own papers.
You want to try to make the
ideas as clear as possible.
You want to lay
the groundwork so
that what you're
about to show is
going to be-- the
reader's going to feel
is a really important thing.
And then you want to take
nice advantage of color
and some legends that are there.
So we'll kind of talk about
all these issues as we go.
But before we get
started, can somebody--
there's a very real sense
that in this field of decision
making and systems biology that
a lot of this research program
is kind of driven by
following classic ideas
from other fields.
And what would be the
corresponding classic idea
this paper is exploring?
AUDIENCE: Conditioning.
PROFESSOR: Conditioning.
Right.
And whose name do we associate
with conditioning typically?
AUDIENCE: Pavlov.
PROFESSOR: Pavlov.
All right.
So I have not ever
read these studies.
Pavlovian conditioning.
And I think that this is
just-- it's good to highlight.
This is something
that you might have
learned in your high
school psychology class.
And it's, again, a big idea,
but it's not the kind of thing--
we've all heard--
well, we're going
to talk about this in a moment.
Many of us, I think,
have heard of this.
But this is an example
of how you take something
that you learned in
high school and you
make it useful to your daily
life, or pseudo daily life.
Because I think you'll see that
there are many kind of examples
of this throughout
this literature,
where someone takes an
idea that is, in some ways,
you open up a random textbook
in introductory psychology,
and you can just
march through and try
to see to what degree the
ideas that were developed
in the context of
humans or animals,
to what degree might they be
relevant in the context of cell
decision making?
Can somebody just say what is
this Pavlovian conditioning
idea?
Did you guys take high
school psychology?
I'm sure somebody did.
No.
All right.
Well, incidentally,
I recommend everybody
should take a solid
introductory psychology
class if you have not done so.
We offer a class 900.
I'm sure that it's
good and interesting.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So there's two
different events or stimuli,
and in Pavlovian conditioning
you give one and then
always give the
other one following.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So there's some sense
that what we might call--
there are two
events of some sort.
One is following the other one,
so it's A and then followed
by B. And people have done many
different examples of this,
but what's the one
that we typically--
what's the classic
experiment that Pavlov did?
AUDIENCE: You ring a bell,
and then you get food.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
So you ring a bell and then
you give-- and this is dogs,
at least in the
version I remember.
So you have some dogs,
you do this thing
where you ring the bell and
then you give them the food.
And what's the response
that you're supposed to get?
AUDIENCE: Drooling.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So the dog is supposed
to start salivating.
OK.
So you might think
your experiments
are gross, but-- right.
So ring a bell, and the idea
is that you can train the dog
to start salivating in response
to the bell, rather than,
of course, if you
give the food they're
going to start salivating.
But here you can train the
dog to start salivating
in response to the food.
So now, with training,
this results in salivation.
And did Pavlov show there was
a fitness benefit associated
with the salivation?
Not that I'm not I'm aware of.
But this is the classic
story that we learned
in introductory psychology.
And the question is, can
we apply a similar idea
in the case of microbial
decision making?
Now was this-- can
somebody say what
they think was the
author's contribution
to the literature in the
sense of-- via a vis this?
How much of what-- well, we
can be maybe more concrete.
In the case of E. coli,
what was known-- or maybe
we should describe the
experiment once more
and then try to figure out
what they did that was new new.
At least can somebody kind
of summarize the basic idea
with E. coli?
AUDIENCE: We know that they have
a certain metabolic life cycle
and that they exist in
different environments.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that E. coli existent
in different environments.
And what environments
are you referring to?
AUDIENCE: Gut and outside.
PROFESSOR: Gut and outside.
So if this is
true-- then what is
going to be your next
statement based on this?
AUDIENCE: Well, going
through mammalian guts
there's always a certain
sequence of events.
At the beginning, there's
some acid, and then
less acid and more food,
and stuff like that.
PROFESSOR: RIght.
So in the context of E.
coli, there's this idea
that part of the
life cycle of E. coli
and some other of
these microbes is
to live inside the
gut of mammals.
And we're going to
focus in particular
on this aspect, the part of the
life cycle that is in the gut.
So let's just imagine, so E.
coli in gut or entering gut,
going through the gut,
they might encounter
some sort of typical
environmental cues,
or maybe orders of
environmental exposure.
And actually, even
before this paper,
there was another paper that was
published by Saeed Tavazoie--
hard name to pronouce-- who
was at Princeton at the time.
So he had published a
Science paper just the year
before-- well, couple years
before-- demonstrating
a related phenomenon.
What was it that this other
paper had demonstrated?
Does anybody remember
from the introduction?
So it wasn't the experiment
that these guys did.
But in the
introduction they spent
half of a paragraph describing
this other experiment.
Another kind of
environmental cue
that E. coli get when
they enter the gut.
So what's-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't there a
temperature increase and oxygen
decrease?
PROFESSOR: Temperature
increase and oxygen decrease.
So temperature goes up
and oxygen goes down.
And this makes sense.
The inside of our
bodies typically
warmer than outside our body.
Also, it's a relatively
anaerobic environment
inside the gut as compared
to the ready availability
of oxygen outside.
So what is it that this
other paper then showed?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I think
they were trying
to show a symmetric
response [INAUDIBLE].
If adaptation in one
situation occurred,
then-- if it received
one stimulus,
it would adapt to both.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
And the word adapt, we always
have to be very careful,
because it could mean two
very different things.
And in some cases, it might
be that both-- possibly it
might be true, but when
you say that it receives
one stimuluss-- so
this we might call S1,
and this is S2-- so these
are stimuli that the cell
senses-- are you saying
that it might sense one,
and then it adapts to both.
When you say adapt,
are you referring
to evolutionary adaptation
or something else?
AUDIENCE: I'm referring
to a single cell
implementing the
appropriate metabolic--
PROFESSOR: That sort of
cell level adaptation.
The sort of default thing
is you might, say, well,
if you get the stimuli one
and increase the temperature,
you should implement the program
one or the response one that
corresponds to some set
of genes that are required
to grow in high temperature.
Now similarly with stimulus
2-- well, we'll say this is R2.
So these could, in principal,
have different gene network
responses to these two
environmental changes.
But what they found is that
actually, if you take E. coli
and you expose it to
increase in temperature,
then not only does it
activate the genes required
to handle high temperature,
but also activates
the genes required handle
low oxygen, and vice versa.
Now there's a question, though.
If you see this, it
could just be the case
that you've mislabeled
what really is R1, R2.
Maybe it's just a single
R, single response
that allows the population
to adapt to both
of those environmental changes.
Does anybody remember
what the authors
did to show that that was
maybe not what was going on?
You can look at your sheet
of paper while I--I just want
to write down the reference
in case anybody wants to look
at this more.
This is Tagkopoulos,
Science 2008.
What would you do if
you wanted to show
that this was a real
regulatory strategy,
this so-called symmetric
anticipatory regulation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Would it
be you could measure
genes' pressure
somehow, and then you
could get the function of each
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you could expose
to this stimulus,
measure gene expression, expose
to this stimulus, measures gene
expression, and try
to figure out, maybe,
based on the difference
which genes were more
or less-- but the
argument was somehow
that in response to stimulus
1, there were some genes that
were really unnecessary.
So I guess you could
go and you could
do knockouts of each
of these 100 genes,
and then try to
measure the effects.
And that would be
a nice direct--
and it's related to something
that they did in this paper
with the yeast.
They went and looked at the
gene expression profiles.
What they did in
this paper by Saeed
was that they took
the E. coli that
displayed this, what they're
arguing is a symmetric--
and based on some
previous studies, I think,
saying that, oh, this had
been annotated to be good
for temperature but not
for oxygen and vice versa.
So there were already hints
that this kind of made sense.
But what they did is they
evolved the populations
in just one of
these environments
and showed that they
could decouple them.
So that's at least
making you feel
that it's a little bit--
that maybe this was not
due to just some sense that
it's the same genes that
are required for protection
against these two environments,
but rather that because they
had evolved in this environment
where, when they see an
increase in temperature,
they often see a
decrease in oxygen.
AUDIENCE: So when
you say decoupled,
you mean you evolve them in
high-temperature environments?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: You expose
them to decreased oxygen,
and then they die?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no, no.
So just, they showed that
if you evolve the population
so that it receives this
stimulus without this stimulus,
then it removes
this arrow, that it
stops activating these genes.
And then I think
they also did look
at the functional consequences.
But the first
order thing is just
that they saw that
they could remove
one of these arrows, which is
related to something that they
do here as well.
Now I think that
it's worth thinking
about the question of
whether this study, published
in Science in 2008,
do you think that it's
a complete scoop of the
paper that you just read,
which is Amir Mitchell's paper
published in Nature in 2009?
No.
OK.
And on one level you
say, well, they still
got it published in Nature, so
therefore it was not a scoop.
But I can tell you that
Amir was very worried,
because he had been working
on this paper for many years.
And they really studied
both E. coli and yeasts.
It was a major thing.
And then this paper
came out, and I'm
sure that he was despondent.
And there will be
times where you
feel despondent as a
result of something
like this coming out, because it
really is a very similar idea.
The E. coli stuff
is very similar,
because it's same organism--
the idea is, in the gut.
So in what ways do you think
that their paper is different,
and also, what
strategies did they
follow in order to
differentiate their paper?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
potentially trying
to find differing regulation
mechanisms, so they said, well,
there's a symmetric
regulation mechanism
that someone talked
about last year,
and we've got the
asymmetric one.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And I think that
this is-- of course,
we cannot replay history.
But I think that they do a
very nice thing in figure one
of laying the groundwork
to make it very clear
that their work is
different from Saeed's work.
And the thing is that if
this had not been published,
they maybe would have framed
their work differently.
They might not have
had this difference
between a symmetrical
anticipatory regulation
and the asymmetrical.
But by laying
things out that way,
it clarifies that, oh yeah,
these are different things.
And they're going
to explore this one,
whereas Saeed's
group had explored
a rather different mechanism.
But then, of course, depending
on how you look at it,
they're either more
or less similar.
But I think that they do a
very nice job of kind of right
at the beginning setting
out how their work is
going to be different.
So they explained that there's
the simple direct sensing
mechanisms.
You'd say that you just
have different stimuli that
lead to different responses.
That's fine.
They also have the
stochastic switching, which
we're going to talk about more.
The idea here is
that even though we
might be getting different
stimuli at some rates,
we would still switch into
these different responses.
And we'll talk about various
reasons that this might happen.
Incidentally, these
things don't have
to happen at the same rates.
So it could be that stimulus
one it primarily does R1,
whereas stimulus 2 primarily
does R2, for example.
If you'd like, these arrows
could have different strengths.
But then what they do is they
point out that there really
are-- well, this symmetric
anticipatory regulation,
where it's crossed,
maybe I'll just
write out the asymmetric one.
Can somebody say
why it is that we
might want to do the
asymmetrical as compared
to the symmetrical?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If both of the stimuli
are appearing at the same time,
then you might want to have
a symmetric anticipatory
regulation?
PROFESSOR: Great.
So the important thin
is here that this
is, because it's at the same
time, the two stimuli kind
of come together, or very
similar times, whereas this,
if there's a clear
temporal order.
But you could think about
this in some other way
as well, maybe.
Can somebody--
AUDIENCE: It's along
the same lines,
but there's a cost to
having S2 also performing.
Then if you ever use that--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So depending on
the costs, it could
change what's sort of
optimal, perhaps, right?
And I think it's also
perhaps worth just saying
that it may also depend
upon how frequent
these different environmental
perturbations are,
because you can also
imagine situations
where it's very common that
the temperature goes up,
but it's very rare
that oxygen goes down.
But there could be a sense
in which this is, basically,
based on the logic
I just said, this
would be then less
predictive of this
than this would be of this.
Do you guys see what I'm saying?
Because it could be the case
that any time that oxygen goes
down, then you really know that
that means that you're entering
somebody's gut and you
also better activate this,
whereas it could also be
the case that if you sit out
in the sun, you get
hot, it doesn't mean
that oxygen's going to go down.
So it could be that there
is more or less information,
or that each of the stimuli
have more or less information
about another stimuli.
So even if there's
no temporal order,
it could be the case
that something like that
could lead to a situation
where this might be optimal.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
people try to make
formal statements about
information in this context,
just like they did in the
context of stochastic theory.
PROFESSOR: So
there's some of it.
I haven't seen anything
that's quite as
clear and formal as what Edo
Kussell did in that Science
paper you guys just read.
But for example,
Amir did do a paper,
he wrote a PNAS paper basically
laying out this model that's
sort of sketched at the end
of this paper a little bit
in more detail in
terms of explaining,
depending on the probability
that something occurs
and the time, so
kind of exploring
this a bit more,
but not as formal
in terms of information as--
AUDIENCE: So it's
not quite clear to me
why you would have a symmetric
anticipatory regulation
comparing direct sensing.
If you have direct sensing,
you can do the same thing.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I think it's true.
But it could also be that
because these things are
both fluctuating and
they are measured
with some noise and
the environment,
there could be a sense that--
because you can imagine
a world in which
these two things are
both uncertain predictors of
whether you're in the gut.
But if they both
go, then that really
means something, in which
case then it would make sense
to really look at both of them
and activate both more strongly
as a result of seeing both.
AUDIENCE: But it
could also make you
more susceptible to
trigger a response that you
don't necessarily want.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
But if you say, oh, well
this happens at a low rate
and this happens
at a low rate, then
the probability that both of
them happen at the same time
would be very small.
So your rate of false
positive, in that sense,
would be-- you can really reduce
the rate of false positives
by integrating both
pieces of information.
And this paper, just
to remind ourselves,
this paper is
primarily exploring
the idea of asymmetrical
anticipatory regulation.
And their argument
is because there's
a typical temporal order to
how E. Coli that are ingested
encounter different sugar.
And the claim in the paper is
that bacteria will typically
see what before what?
AUDIENCE: Lactose
before maltose.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
So the claim is that in the gut,
the bacteria will see lactose
before they see maltose.
Now in order to evolve this
asymmetrical anticipatory
regulation, does it have to
be that you kind of always
see lactose before
you see maltose?
So let's imagine that only 10%
of the time that the bacteria
see lactose-- or sorry,
only 10% of the time
that the bacteria encounter
maltose that they actually saw
lactose before.
Since 10% is much less
than 1, should that totally
scotch this whole mechanism?
No.
And can you say why not?
AUDIENCE: Every time they
see lactose they see maltose.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
In some ways, that's
not the right way
to think about it, but in
terms of a cost-benefit type
argument, why is it that
maybe it's OK in principle
that maltose is frequently
observed without lactose?
AUDIENCE: There's no difference
between the two strains
if you see maltose that way.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And I think this is a kind of
an interesting, important point,
which is that if you imagine a
competition between the strain
that just does, we can imagine,
direct sensing versus we'll
call that AAR.
So direct sensing versus
asymmetrical anticipatory
regulation.
Now if you imagine the
situation where you encounter
maltose without encountering
lactose, then these two
strategies behave
essentially identically,
because they both
just see the maltose,
they're both surprised.
They both activate the mall
genes, everything's fine.
However, it's in
this other direction
that you have to think about it.
So the real question is,
when you encounter lactose,
you want to think about, well,
what fraction of the time
and how long a delay is there
before you encounter maltose?
Because if it's the case that
you encounter lactose a lot,
and only infrequently do
you then come on to maltose,
that's going to be a
problem for evolving this
into asymmetrical
anticipatory regulation,
or it would not necessarily
be optimal to do so,
because in that case you're
going to be activating
all those mall genes in
advance, and frequently it
won't be useful.
And this is relevant, perhaps,
just because what fraction
of the time do you think
that E. coli going to the gut
will encounter lactose?
We should be able to make a
reasonable estimate of this,
is my claim.
All right.
Where does lactose come from?
Lactose comes from milk.
Which animals drink milk?
Well, right, OK.
So we're thinking about mammals.
Just take a random
mammal of your choice.
You might want to
not choose humans
just because we're a little
bit atypical in this regard,
although even there
I think the numbers
end up being kind of the same.
But imagine a dog or a bear
or your favorite mammal.
Which of them are drinking milk?
The young, right?
OK.
So there's some period of one's
life where you drink milk,
and then as an adult
you typically don't.
I guess all I'm
saying is that if you
imagine the bacteria entering
into a mammalian gut,
it might be 20%.
I don't know what,
but it's basically
proportional to the years.
The kids, they may
eat more dirty things.
So you have to wait or whatever.
The point is that they're
going to encounter lactose
if they enter the gut of
a baby or young child,
whereas if you enter an adult,
then you won't see lactose,
and you'll just maybe then
directly see the maltose.
But there's no real
cost associated
with missing that
signal vis a vis
the so-called direct strategy.
I think that they do lay out
some other kind of conditions
that they think would be
reasonable to demonstrate
if you want to do the
asymmetrical anticipatory
regulation.
And once again, I think
that this is both very clear
and also just lays
the groundwork
for the reader in the
sense that they tell you
what they would need to show in
order for you to be convinced.
And then they go and
they do those things.
Now in principle,
you could argue
about one or the other things.
But I think they
do such a nice job
of being clear about what would
be needed that you don't even
think to object about any of it.
And of course they're not going
to bring up the three things
that they would
need to demonstrate
unless they actually were able
to demonstrate those three
things.
So the three things
that they claim
is that for this to have been an
evolved trait that pre-exposure
to S1 increases the
fitness under S2 or R2--
I guess in this
case-- that's right.
So getting S1 helps you in S2.
So seeing lactose
helps you in maltose.
Indeed they're
going to show that.
Second, that there's
some cost associated
with up regulating
that, in this case
up regulating the mall genes.
And third, there's this
idea of specificity.
Now the claim is
that it's really
S1 that is activating
this R2 response,
and that various other S's, in
this case other sugar sources,
maybe should not pre-activate.
Now in figure 1,
they basically are
exploring the difference
between this arrow and this one.
So if you expose
the cells to maltose
you activate the mall
genes at a high level.
Is it required that
exposure to lactose up
regulates the mall genes to
the same level as maltose?
No.
Was it at the same
level as maltose?
No.
But the idea is it up
regulates it some, as compared
to other carbon sources.
Now they also made a comment
about whether this arrow,
the so-called
anticipatory regulation,
whether it was specific
to their E. coli strain,
and their claim was
that it was or was not?
Would it be good for it to
be specific to their strain,
or bad?
Probably bad, although the
fact that-- but then they
say, oh, it's not
specific to our strain.
And then they cite another
paper, which-- and this
is, again, a nice
way of phrasing
it because they're adding
strength to their paper
because they're saying, oh,
it's not just our strain.
It's in other strains as well.
So you read that sentence
and say yes, that's good.
Of course you could
read that sentence
and say, oh, but somebody
else already showed this?
But this is, again--
and I don't have
any real complaint about that,
because I think what they've
done is they've really
brought a set of measurements
together in one
conceptual framework
that I think is
rather compelling.
Now of course, you
can always argue about
whether each of
these examples really
did evolve for this purpose
or not and so forth.
But just because
somebody else had
seen that there was some
cross-regulation of the mall
genes in response to lactose.
Doesn't mean that this
paper is worthless.
But it is interesting to note
that somebody else had already
seen this.
Moreover, in figure
one they compare
this asymmetrical anticipatory
regulation for their wild type
strain as compared
to another strain.
And what other
strain did they use?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You didn't
expose the cells to maltose
after the lactose [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
They evolved the cells in
lactose for 500 generations.
And then what did they see?
AUDIENCE: The arrow.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
When they saw was that
evolution-- and this
is in lactose-- removed that.
Now 500 generations,
how long do you think
this is going to take them?
AUDIENCE: A few months.
PROFESSOR: A few months.
Have you guys ever
heard of any other paper
where they evolved E. coli in
lactose for 500 generations
in your extensive
reading of the literature
that you've engaged
in over this semester?
AUDIENCE: The
cost-benefit paper.
PROFESSOR: The
So it's fascinating to note
that this sentence, they said,
"We have examined
laboratory-evolved strains
of E. coli.
Did they say that they
did the evolution?
No, they didn't.
And indeed, if you follow
Citation 14 over here,
you can say, oh, right.
So it's another paper
by Uri and company.
So I don't know if it was
the exact same experiment,
but the idea is
that-- so I think
what they did is, they
took the strains that
were evolved for another
purpose, and that's fine.
If somebody else already
did the daily dilutions
for three months that is the
exact same that you were going
to do, then you
might as well just
analyze their evolved
strains, right?
There's nothing that says you
have to go and repeat the work.
You would get the same
thing, maybe, presumably.
So this is just
worth highlighting.
But it makes the
paper much stronger
that they were able to do that.
So it's good to keep in mind
that in some cases, what you
need to do to make your
point has already been done
or has already been
evolved and so forth.
So now what we
have is a situation
where somebody else,
maybe, has already seen
that lactose activates maltose.
Somebody else already did
this evolution on lactose.
They didn't yet show that
this regulation was removed.
So that was something
that these guys had to do,
and indeed, it looks
like it's removed.
But once again, I think there's
a sense that they're really
looking at this problem
from kind of a new, maybe
comprehensive way
that allows them
to see the connections
between all
these different experiments.
And then they are
doing new measurements.
But the measurements themselves
are perhaps relatively simple,
but the trick is knowing
what measurements
you need to do in
order to say something
that's very interesting.
So in figure three, what
they went and they did is
they asked about this question
of whether there really
is a fitness benefit
associated with it.
Now I think this is
another case where
you could have made this
figure in the form of a table,
and it just would not
be very compelling.
So you'd look at it and you just
wouldn't be very excited by it,
whereas in this case, they
have the figure, which
are these fitness advantages
associated with whether you
take the strains, you first
expose them to lactose and then
go to maltose, or
you go from maltose
to lactose, or in this case GAL
to maltose, sucrose to maltose.
What they showed was it was
a selective benefit there,
that the cells really only gain
the benefit of pre-exposure
to a sugar if it's lactose.
And they show that for
the evolved strain,
not only does it no
longer have that arrow
in the sense of the response,
but it also no longer
has the benefit.
It's good to do both
of those measurements
because it's possible you
might have missed something.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So but like, it's for
one protocol going from lactose
to maltose.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yep.
And this is the
nature of science,
or in particular this
kind of science, I think,
that you can
collect data that is
consistent with
this interpretation,
but it does not at all prove
that this is not gut, either.
And so you could have
imagined experiments
where you maybe mixed
two strains that
follow this direct
versus the AAR,
and you mix them together
50-50 in the gut.
And then you go and you
do sequencing later.
And actually, people do
such kinds of experiments,
and in some cases, amazingly,
sometimes something
comes out the other end
that is interesting.
I couldn't help myself.
Sorry about that.
So yes.
One other point on this
paper, or this figure,
that they even color
code the data points.
So they have their main
thing in this black,
but then the other ones
are red, yellow, blue.
it's telling us that this
thing is directional.
It's S1, S2, S2, S1,
specificity, extinction.
So they are even
kind of telling us
what each of those
data points mean.
And you might say, oh,
that's kind of overkill.
But given that it's just
so important that you're
keeping track of why we're
doing each of these measurements
and what it's supposed to
tell us about the big story,
I think that it's really just
wonderful to be reminded,
OK, what is this controlling
for, or what not.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I like the colors
too, but they don't stand out
very well in black and white.
PROFESSOR: Yes, well, OK.
So we can lead entire
discussions about both
how to write a paper
and how to read a paper.
How to read a paper is
that you should just
get a color printer, OK?
So that's the advice.
In terms of how
to write a paper,
I would say, though,
that it's always
good-- you should take
advantage of colors,
but you should choose the
color scheme/scale such
that it is legible or
compelling in both color
and black and white.
And actually there's
a very nice set
of articles written by Wong,
who's a graphic artist that
works at the Broad.
He wrote maybe 15 different kind
of one- or two-page articles
for Nature Methods,
basically just
about how to write figures.
And he talks about these
different color scales.
You know, there's-- what
do the words mean when
there's brightness?
Color, hue, saturation.
I can't remember what all
these things mean anymore.
But that's why you
should read the articles.
And it's fascinating
stuff, actually.
So this is the basic argument
they made in this paper,
that because E. coli are exposed
to a typical order of carbon
sources in the mammalian
gut, that that's
the possible explanation for
why this thing evolved that they
can measure
experimentally, which
is that when, these E.
coli, they see lactose,
they start activating the
mall genes but not vice versa.
Now, like always,
you can't prove
that this is what's going on.
I think very interesting
set of ideas.
Some of the people that
study gut microbes just
think that it's implausible that
this would actually work out
in the sense that the fitness
cost benefits, et cetera,
would be relevant.
Do we know that the time
scales even work out?
I don't know how-- so
there are a bunch of things
that you could worry about.
And I would say I don't
know enough about what
goes on in the gut to
actually have an educated
opinion on that point.
But I think it's a very kind of
clear exposition of the ideas.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a sense for what
fraction of E. coli bacteria
are in the gut of animals?
Do you see what I mean?
Because it's just a
very small fraction.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, and I guess--
so I myself definitely
do not know what fraction
of E.coli are in the gut as
compared to in the
soil or in the--
it's not that E. coli are the
dominant bacteria in our gut,
either.
It's just that they do
enter the gut at some rate.
And then the question is,
if we knew the answer,
I don't even know if it
would tell us-- I mean,
it gives some guidance.
But there's also a
question of where
is it that cells are
actually dividing,
because it could be the
case that the life cycle is
that they go in the
gut, and that's where
they're dividing and happy.
And then they end up
in some soil somewhere,
and they're in some stationary
phase, and maybe most of them
are dying at some small rate.
Eventually some of
them get uptaken again
and then they divide,
divide, divide.
So it could be the cases that
only 0.1% of all E. coli,
or 01% of the time.
It could be a very small
amount of time or something,
and they're in the
gut, but it could still
be the dominant
event in their lives.
So I just don't know.
I think I'm maybe going to skip
the second half of the talk,
or second half of the
paper, where they discuss
this idea of the typical
order of events in which yeast
in the context of
fermentation and making wine
might encounter or experience
different environmental
assaults.
And it's a similar kind of
idea of cross-protection
against different assaults.
But in some ways,
this is really sort
of two mini-papers
that tie together
in this general thing of
anticipatory regulation.
Are there any questions
about this before we move on?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about when
the baby males grow up.
Do they need this mechanism?
Do E. coli?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So your question is whether
E. coli in the gut of adults
have this.
I don't know, but my feeling is
that these things are probably
fairly transient in the
sense that you probably
don't have-- well, certainly,
from the standpoint of entering
the gut, the bacteria
don't have any choice
about whose gut they enter.
So it probably is going
to be the case that they
have to have a
basic strategy that
is going to work across
both adults and the kids,
although it's true that
the gut communities in kids
are different from adults.
But it's hard to know
what to make of that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So here they
decouple the two responses.
Are there any examples of
researchers coupling them,
like Pavlov's?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a good question.
I know that I've heard
people talking about it,
but I can't point to
a specific example
of where it's been convincing.
That doesn't mean it's
not out there, though.
It's a very important,
interesting question.
So what we want to now
is kind of switch gears
a little bit and switch
to this topic of-- it's
going to be kind of partly
about phenotypic heterogeneity,
but partly again about
fluctuating environments.
And the way that those
two topics are related
is via bet hedging,
but I just want
to highlight that bet
hedging is a way of using
phenotypic heterogeneity in
order to survive fluctuating
environments, whereas it's
not the only explanation
for this phenotypic
heterogeneity.
So yeah, I think maybe
we'll-- so first of all,
on the topic of
phenotypic heterogeneity,
when we say that we are often
referring to the fact that even
clonal populations can be
remarkably heterogeneous
in a given environment.
So we'll say phenotypic
heterogeneity
in clonal populations,
because of course,
if there's a lot of genetic
diversity in the population,
then it's not, perhaps,
a surprise there would
be phenotypic heterogeneity.
What we're going to do
is go through these three
different possible explanations
and discuss, maybe,
canonical biological
examples of each.
And the examples that
we're going to give-- well,
the classic example is in the
context of seed germination.
But more recently
there's this question
of the persister cells, or
the persistence phenotype.
Now in both of these
cases, it's really
a way in which a
clonal population can
send a small population
of either seeds or cells
into a protected state that's
protected against some assault.
So seed germination,
this is a case
where the seed, if
it doesn't germinate,
it's protected against draughts.
Draught.
And this one, maybe,
is antibiotics.
What I want to do
is just make sure
that we understand the
seed germination idea.
And so this is, from the
standpoint of ecology,
these ideas came out
in the '70s, at least.
So what we can imagine is a
situation where you are some,
maybe, desert annual.
And so you send out these seeds.
Now most of the time,
you get enough rain,
the seeds are fine.
They can germinate, sprout
the little seedlings,
and they'll be able
to grow up just fine.
But at some rate there
might be a severe drought
that would kill all the cells
that actually germinated.
So the question is, what
might be the optimal strategy?
So for example,
let's just imagine
that we live in a world
in which 75% of the time
there's rain, 25% of the
time there's no rain.
Now if you germinate--
so a particular seed,
if it germinates,
it pops out-- then
it will expect to send two
seeds to the following year,
whereas as it germinates
and there's no rain,
then it only has a 10%
probability of surviving,
or that it could on
average send 1/10 of a seed
to the next generation.
Now of course, you
don't have to germinate.
If you don't germinate,
then what happens
is that you just send one
seed to the next year.
If you'd like, you can
include some probability
that the seed doesn't survive,
but for simplicity, we
can do that.
So the idea is that you don't
know whether it's going to rain
or not.
But what you can do is you
can either germinate or not
germinate.
And then this tells us
how many seeds make it
to the following year.
Do you understand the framework?
So the question is, which
one of these strategies
has a higher long
term growth rate
in terms of the number
of seeds that you
have in the population?
I'm going to give
you 30 seconds just
to kind of think
about this, play
with the numbers a little bit.
And the question
is, should you just
have a strategy where you
germinate or don't germinate?
And then what we're
going to find,
maybe, is that the
optimal strategy is
to do this probabilistically.
But it's useful to just
play with such numbers
for a little bit.
The physics office,
unfortunately,
is trying to steal our cards
from us, so we don't have them.
But what we're
going to instead do
is, if you think you
want to germinate
you raise your left hand.
If you don't want to germinate,
raise your right hand.
OK.
Ready, 3, 2, 1.
So we have a fair
distribution of-- it really
is kind of 50-50.
That's interesting.
All right, let's go ahead and--
yeah, let's spend a minute.
Turn to your neighbor and try to
convince them that it's either
better to germinate or not.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
You can start with 100 of one,
100 of another, and then just--
AUDIENCE: Start with 100
and then you just go--
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: Let's
say 10 to the 4.
So we're trying to
not think about this--
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
So there's another
question about short term
versus long term.
And we're actually trying
to not worry about that.
So you can think about large
populations, so it's really--
AUDIENCE: This is
after one year.
You will maximize
your expected value.
PROFESSOR: That's why
I said the long term
growth of the population.
So if we just compare--
so why don't we reconvene.
Various people have been
talking about the question
of how many seeds
you're starting with,
what the population
size is, because you
have to worry about extinction.
And that's another kind
of interesting question
of short term versus long
term payouts of fitness.
That's actually not
the effect that we're
trying to get at right now.
So we can even think about
this in the limit of just
large population sizes.
And we want to compare
the two strategies.
And for any strategy
you choose, including
the probabilistic
strategies, there's
going to be a long term
growth rate of the population.
So it will grow or shrink
exponentially over time.
And what you want
to do is you want
to find the strategy, in
the context of bet hedging,
you want to find the strategy
that maximizes this long term
growth rate of the population.
And this is essentially what
Edo talks about in his paper,
but in a more mathematical,
general-- because he's talking
about n different
phenotypes and environments
and arbitrary switching rates.
And it's beautiful and general
and he makes nice connections
to information theory.
But it's possible to read
that paper and then not
actually understand
what bet hedging,
or what any of these
things are, quite.
So it's good to take
the simple thing,
and then it's also good to
know that somebody like Edo
has thought about
this very deeply
and figured out all
these beautiful things.
And I know that paper was hard,
so don't-- but it's really like
a two-page paper if
you look at the text.
So it shouldn't take
too much time just
to get a sense of what
he's thinking about.
But then it's good, also, to be
concrete in a simple situation.
So what we want to know is
that, over the long term--
then what you can do
is you can just say,
well, the ratios of rain,
no rain over the long term
will be 3 to 1, because
it's over a long term.
It doesn't matter what
order they come in
because over the long run
it's all going to average out.
We're assuming we're a
large population size,
so we don't have to worry
about stochastic extinction.
The question is,
since we don't have
to worry about
stochastic extinction,
then can we just
say that we just
calculate, for example,
the mean weighted
by these fractions
of these numbers?
And actually, the
subtle possible thing
is that it's the geometric
mean that is relevant,
not the normal mean.
And that's somehow tricky
when given these numbers.
But it's sort of obvious if
you just switch this to a 0.
Because if this is a
0, then is germinate
going to be a good strategy?
No, right?
Because what that would mean
is that if everybody always
germinates, it may be that
this number could be 1,000,
and it's wonderful except
that if, at some low rate,
there's no rain and this is a
0, then the population's dead.
And you'll always
encounter that eventually.
So that just
highlights that it's
the geometric mean you
want to be focusing on.
And in particular, we know that
on average, over the long term,
there are going to be three
of these years for each
of these years.
So we can just
multiply the numbers.
So it's really going to be
there's going to be three times
where you double for each one
time that you divide by 10.
What you see is that
over the long run,
this population shrinks, whereas
in this case it's 1 times
1 times 1 times 1.
So the long term
growth rate/shrinking
rate of these populations
is that in the long run
this population does
not change in size,
whereas over the long run,
this population shrinks.
AUDIENCE: So in the geometric
mean the expected change
in the log population, which
is also the expected percentage
change in the population.
Is that right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I think that if
you take the logs,
it ends up being equivalent.
But you have to make
sure you just do it all.
And I guess what I want to
highlight in this case is that,
A, you have to be careful
of taking averages, but B,
to get the intuition
behind the situations
where bet hedging, I
think, is really valuable,
it's situations where
this thing gets very small
and this might
become rather large.
So you can imagine
that this could be 200
and this could be
10 to the minus 9.
Or if you'd like, you
could say that's 0.
And it's clear that
if this is 0, then
you can't germinate
all the time,
because then the
population's definitely
going to go extinct
over the long run.
But this is also
a situation where
there's real tension between
long term and short term
situations if this
probability is very small.
But it's in these
situations that it
pays, in terms of the long run
growth rate of the population,
to do this some
fraction of the time.
And it could be very small.
It could be that only one
in 10 to the 4 of the cells
enter this persister state that
is resistant to antibiotics.
But it can maximize
the long term growth
rate of the population.
There are various
models that you
can write down for either seed
germination or this or that.
But the relevant thing is, for
example, in the persister case,
it might be that the rate
of persister formation
might only be one cell in
10 to the 5 or 10 to the 6.
So a very small
sub-population of the cells
are in this so-called
persister state.
But those cells, they have
a couple of properties.
One is that they
are dividing slowly.
That means there really is a
cost to entering that persister
state, but if it's only
one of 10 to the 5,
that means that it's really
a rather small cost in terms
of decreasing the growth
of the population.
And those cells also could
be resistant to antibiotics.
So you can select
for them in the sense
that you add a
bunch of antibiotics
and maybe only the persister
cells are left after 12 hours.
But even though I say
you selected for them,
it's not a true antibiotic
resistance kind of mutation,
because if you take that
persister population,
you let it grow
back up, what you
find is that it is still
sensitive to the antibiotic.
Now it's also possible that
at some low rate, maybe one
in 10 to the 8, you evolve
resistance to an antibiotic.
That's genetic resistance
that stays with you,
whereas the persister
kind of resistance, this
is something that is
a phenotypic switch.
And when it grows
back up, it kind of
reverts back to the
original phenotype,
which is being sensitive
to the antibiotic.
So that's the classic
way that you distinguish
between genetic resistance
and this persister-based or
phenotypic resistance.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What would
be the mechanism
of something like that?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So people argue a fair
amount about this.
And there's a thought
that there are
these toxin, anti-toxin modules
in bacteria that are normally
suppressed but can be
triggered, and then
can lead to these
states entering,
although this ends up kind of
a muddy debate/subject somehow.
But the idea is that there's
something in the cell that
is normally repressed,
but then at some rate
activates and causes the
cell to-- and of course,
you can always argue, OK, did it
evolve for this purpose or not?
Because also, if
you're dividing slowly,
then you're going to be
resistant to many things.
But then there's also arguments
that there are somehow
more specific
persister-type states
against particular assaults
or particular antibiotics.
So I think that there
are many subtleties
to this whole debate.
Any other questions about
this idea of bet hedging?
So I think that bet
hedging is indeed
one possible way
in which evolution
could select for phenotypic
heterogeneity in a population.
So this is a population of seeds
that are all, in principle,
identical.
You put them out and
you plant them all
and they see the
same environment.
They don't all germinate.
But it's not that all those
seeds that didn't germinate
are dead, because actually,
the following year, they still
go back and they can follow
some stochastic strategy.
So I just want to stress
that right now we're
considering the two extremes,
but for bet hedging,
you say probability germinate,
1 minus p, don't germinate.
And those are, in general, going
to be some probability p that
can be non-0 that
maximizes long term growth
rate of the population.
But I do want to talk about two
other possible explanations,
which is this idea of mixed
strategies and altruism.
Now mixed strategies,
in some ways,
is an obvious one,
because we just
got done talking about mixed
strategies in game theory,
where there is this notion
that in a given game,
sometimes this Nash equilibrium
was a pure strategy,
or the evolutionary
stable state.
But sometimes at the
equilibrium there
was coexistence of
these two strategies,
and that could be
either implemented
by two different genotypes, or
by one genotype implementing
both phenotypes.
So this was the classic
game that people talk about
in this area is
this hawk dove game.
We talked about this just
a little bit in class.
So this is a model
of animal conflict.
And the idea is the
animals can either
be-- so the idea is that
there are two animals
and they come across
some resource.
And the resource could
be food or it could
be a mate or something else.
And the question is,
should those animals
fight for the resource
or should they back down?
Now the assumption
in all this is
that the hawk is the strategy
that fights and the dove
is the strategy that backs down.
Now the question
is, how do we assign
some sort of costs and benefits
to these various strategies?
Again, where this is
the situation where
we take the two-player
game and then
we'll kind of generalize
it to the population.
Well, if two doves
encounter each other,
then they don't need
to fight at all,
and they just split the benefit.
So there's some benefit
to the resource,
and they each get half of it.
Now of course, if a
hawk meets a dove,
the hawk actually does better,
because then the hawk gets
the entire benefit, doesn't
have to pay the cost.
So already we can see from
what I've said so far,
is dove a Nash equilibrium?
No, because you can already
see that if your opponent is
a dove, it's better for you.
If you start in the
situation where everybody's
a dove, so everybody's
getting b over 2,
then one individual
has the incentive
to change strategies and
get the full benefit.
That hawk never has to fight
anybody because they will all
back down.
Now of course this
dove that fought
that hawk doesn't get
any of the resource,
but also doesn't have to fight.
However, question is, what
happens if two hawks meet?
And that's a situation
where they really go at it.
And what you might say is,
then, there's a 50-50 shot,
that each individual has a 50%
chance of getting the benefit,
but then also has
to pay this cost.
And then you can
decide whether you
want to have-- so I think
it's normally parameterized
to b minus c over 2.
The idea here is that you
have a 50% chance of getting
the benefit, but you have a 50%
chance of getting beaten up.
OK.
Very simple model.
Now the way that we
normally parameterize
this is that-- let's say
that we want the hawk-- wait,
hold on a second.
Under which circumstances
will the hawk strategy
be a Nash equilibrium?
AUDIENCE: If b is larger than c.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If b is larger than
c, then the hawk
would be a Nash equilibrium,
which is actually what
we don't want in this game.
So what we typically
assume is that the benefit
is less than the cost.
So in that sense, it's somehow
not worth fighting for.
And that means that neither
strategy is a Nash equilibrium.
So neither the hawk nor the
dove is a Nash equilibrium.
And indeed you can calculate
what the Nash equilibrium is,
and the Nash equilibrium is
to follow a mixed strategy
with some probability p star
that is, I think, b over c.
So if there's a
bigger benefit, p star
is the probability of
following the hawk strategy.
But as the costs grow, then this
Nash equilibrium probability
decreases.
So this is a case where
it's a mixed strategy that
is this Nash equilibrium.
And so this is a
situation that displays
what we call negative
frequency dependent selection.
You can see that the
rare strategies do better
than common strategies.
The key way to
think about this is
that if you have a
population of doves,
then a rare hawk does better.
However, if you have
a population of hawks,
then it's a rare dove
that does better.
And it's that kind of negative
frequency of dependence
that pushes the population
towards some equilibrium
between the
phenotypes, or it could
be equilibrium between genotypes
as well, because you could have
pure strategists of a hawk and
a dove, so different genotypes
that just are different.
And the differences in
fitness will naturally
lead to evolution to
an equilibrium hawk
kind of frequency
in the population
that is equal to this.
So this tells us either about
the equilibrium frequency
of the genotype of
hawk in the population.
Or it could be that it's
a single genotype that
implements these two strategies
with some frequency that
is b over c.
So I'd say that this is a simple
idea from the context of game
theory, and the question
is, what circumstances
might this actually arise
in kind of real populations.
Oh, before I say
anything else, I
do want to stress
that all of you
have played mixed strategies
before, because in the Rock
Paper Scissors game, which
we're going to be talking about
more in the coming week or
so-- you guys all know this,
that rock beats-- not paper--
but rock beats scissors,
scissors beats paper,
paper beats rock--
so the Nash equilibrium of that
game is to do 1/3 1/3, 1/3,
because if everybody's
following that strategy,
nobody has the incentive
to change strategies.
Definition of the
Nash equilibrium.
Is that the optimal strategy
against any opponent?
No.
And this is very
important to point out,
because when you think
about these Nash equilibrium
and everything in
abstract terms,
it's easy to get
confused about--
when we say that it's--
sometimes we say optimal,
or it's the solution
to the game,
that doesn't mean that it's
the best response to any given
strategy.
And you know that,
because if you
know that your little brother
is going to play rock, then
you know-- well,
depending on whether you
want to make him happy or not,
you decide what to do, right?
So it's clear that this
1/3, 1/3, 1/3 thing
is, it can be the solution
to the game of the Nash
equilibrium without being the
best response to any given
strategy.
So one of things that
we're doing in my group,
actually, is we're arguing
that in the case of yeasts that
are exposed to mixed
sugar environments--
so yeast in environments that
contain a little bit of glucose
and a little bit of galactose--
what we and actually
other people have found is that
there's a bimodal response.
So if you look at the number of
cells as a function of the GAL
operon expression, so
GAL is the expression
of the genes required to break
down galactose, what you see
is that some of the cells
activate the GAL genes highly,
some don't activate it at all.
So the question
is, what might be
an explanation for this
phenotypic heterogeneity
observed in a clonal population?
And one way to
think about this is
that it could be
the implementation
of some sort of foraging game.
So you can imagine a
population of animals that want
to go and eat some berries.
So there are two
different food sources--
say there are blueberries
and there are red berries.
You can imagine this is
the kind of situation that
would lead to negative
frequency dependence,
because if everybody
else goes and eats--
I guess this was the blueberry--
so if everybody else goes
and eats the blueberries,
then it's better for you
to eat the red berry
because you don't have
to share with anyone, whereas
if everyone else goes and eats
the red berries, then
it's better for you
to eat the blueberries.
So that's the kind of
situation that would naturally
lead to the so-called negative
frequency dependent selection,
in which coexistence
of the phenotypes
is somehow the
equilibrium condition,
and that can be implemented
either by different genotypes
or it can be implemented
by a single genotype that
follows both phenotypes.
Incidentally, is
this equilibrium--
does it maximize the
fitness of the population?
No.
So what is it that
would maximize
the fitness of the population?
If everybody were a dove,
because-- and you can
you go ahead and do
this calculation,
find out what the
fitness of everybody is,
but what you'll see is that p
star does not maximize fitness,
ford not maximize payoff.
So in these games, the
equilibrium is not necessarily
fitness maximizing.
So so far what
we've done is we've
given two examples of
different evolutionary drivers
for phenotypic heterogeneity
in a population.
And I just want
to highlight what
I think is maybe the last big
one, which would be altruism.
And sometimes people call
it division of labor,
or sacrifice or so.
And a nice example of this
is colicin production.
The idea is that
in many bacteria,
they express these
colicin, which are toxins.
And we're going to read
more about this later.
So colicin is a toxin.
And the perhaps
surprising thing is
that in many gram-negative
bacteria, like E. coli, when
they make this colicin,
the only way it's released
is cell lysis.
Now the question is, why
would I possibly do this?
And the answer is,
perhaps, that if there's
a plasmid that encodes the
genes to make this toxin,
it also encodes an
immunity protein.
What that means is that
if one cell lyses--
so it bursts open and
releases the colicin--
it will inhibit other
bacteria, but not
the bacteria that are the
clone mates that are related,
so not the bacteria that
also carry that plasmid.
So it's important to
note there that now when
we talk about kin
selection or relatedness,
we're talking about the other
cells that carry that gene.
So what's relevant is that the
plasma that encodes this toxin
will inhibit other bacteria
that do not encode the toxin.
Now you can see that this
kind of lysis behavior
has to be stochastic,
so there has
to be phenotypic heterogeneity.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: Everyone always lyses.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If this plasmid always
makes everybody lyse,
then it's not going to
get very far, right?
But you can kind of
imagine situations
where, if you just
1% of the population
lyses but then
inhibits the cells that
don't care that plasmid,
then the plasmid
can spread in the population.
So this has to be stochastic.
So I think that this is
another general explanation
for why there might be
phenotypic heterogeneity
in the population.
All of these three explanations
are both conceptually different
and they're
experimentally different.
They make different
falsifiable predictions
about what's driving that
phenotypic heterogeneity.
In this field, I think
often when people
see phenotypic heterogeneity,
they immediately
assume that it's bet
hedging, but these other two
explanations, I think,
are just as general
and may be just as common.
So we really have to go
and make measurements
to try to elucidate what's
going on in each case.